hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Plato's
dialogue the credo Socrates makes a very
important distinction and spells outs in
some implications of that to his his
friend and student credo who has bribed
the guards is ready to take Socrates
away to another place and a saying look
you don't have to stay here and be
executed in Athens Socrates let's get
out while the getting's good
it's the day before or perhaps two days
before he's going to be executed
so credo makes the case to Socrates and
Socrates says well let's let's think
about this that's where this distinction
comes in that is is very important it
runs throughout Plato's works it's also
one that's very important in general for
philosophy and here in this one Plato is
going to frame it in terms of whose
opinions should we care about whose
opinion should actually hold weight
should we pay attention to what the many
think public opinion Society perhaps
even a smaller group you know what our
friends think what our family thinks or
should we have a different criterion for
who's
opinions matter should we look to the
wise or the knowledgeable the person who
actually has some sort of expertise or
competency in an area in a subject in a
matter and Socrates says look credo I
know that you think that the many mattr
but let's remind ourselves about this
sort of thing the opinions of the many
don't really matter because they're not
valuable so let's look at the the many
first and Socrates discussion of that he
says that they can't make a person wise
as a matter of fact they can't even make
a person stupid that's an interesting
thing to say because you would think
that following the opinions of them and
he would actually make the person stupid
but that's the choice of the individual
who doesn't have to follow public
opinion who doesn't have to say well
everybody else thinks this way so I'm
gonna think that way as well credo says
look they can kill you you've got
worried about public opinion because
they can hurt you Socrates says they
can't really hurt you they also can't
really help you if they could in fact
hurt you in what matters the most in
what is is truly valuable then they
could also help you with that but they
can't actually do any of that why well
because they act and decide and talk as
he says at random by chance they're not
fixed they they change their mind from
point to point to point
they don't have consistency even when
they are consistent they don't have good
grounds for their consistency so we
don't want to worry about what the many
think the last thing that he also says
is that look why are their opinions bad
not only are they untruthful but they
lead to harmful consequences and
Socrates uses examples as he often does
to try to drive this home he says if
you're going to go to a personal trainer
you wouldn't want to just pick any you
know Joe off the street or like take a
public opinion thing think of
here in America if you know where we
struggle with obesity and and all sorts
of you know being out of shape and the
sedentary lifestyle if you were just to
go to regular people and say let's just
do it you know public opinion poll how
should I do what sort of exercise
routine should I do and you weren't just
you know looking at what they give lip
service to but in fact how they live
then you would live like the rest of
them and you would probably be you know
not that healthy now on the other hand
if you actually want to know what is
healthy you need to go to somebody who
actually has some competency of that you
know perhaps several people maybe a
dietician should I eat this should I
avoid this or a specialist and exercise
what kind of exercises can I can I begin
doing if I'm out of shape what should I
be building towards how often should I
do it per week you don't just go into
any old person or you know public
opinion writ large you go to somebody
who actually knows something about that
same thing with with money again a great
example here for contemporary Americans
even before the financial crisis we had
a negative savings rate that meant that
people were going further and further
into debt rather than actually
accumulating assets and you know saving
because you know they were they were
engaged in what we call consumer
spending so if you're gonna say well you
know what do a lot of people think we
ought to do you've got some money should
you save it how should you be saving it
or should you go blow it a lot of people
blow it if there's always going to be
other money to be made you don't have to
worry about retirement for a long time
is that what a financial plan I'm going
to tell you a financial planner is
somebody presumably who has some
background in handling money and some
sort of expertise in that and they would
say no actually you need to be saving
some honey so you know we could think
about this with all sorts of things you
know Socrates has examples of you know
horsemanship and exercise and diet but
we can think of this in terms of all
sorts of avenues of our life you know
relationships what kind of house we
ought to
yeah you know if we're gonna have a
house or should we rent or you know what
can a car should I get a new car should
I you know buy old cars and make them
last all these sorts of things we could
go with the many what it is that our
culture what is that public opinion is
telling us or we can go with somebody
who actually knows something so let's
look at the expert now Socrates says
some people at least in some things
actually understand the manner that
we're looking at why do they understand
it because they possess some knowledge
they possess some expertise and where
did they get that from that's a question
that he doesn't actually explore here
but you know we can talk about that in
terms of skills or crafts or sciences in
many other Platonic dialogues here he's
concerned with who actually does
understand the matter and then he know
it's this kind of person is going to be
very helpful
they're good their opinion is good
because it leads to good results the
opinions of the many may seem to be good
in the short term but they're actually
going to be harmful towards you the
opinions of the person who actually has
some knowledge assuming that he's in you
know letting you in on it and he's not
just screwing around with you but he's
really acting in in good faith I'm
telling you this is this would be good
for you this is what you ought to do
that's going to be helpful for you so a
dietician will help you to you know lose
weight or start eating more healthy or
get the nutrients that you need in your
diet a good counselor for anger
management will teach you how to learn
to identify when you're getting angry
and cut that off before it begins to
make you you know lose control we could
go down the list of that sort of things
in this case what are we talking at them
Socrates says the person that we're
really interested in here because we're
talking about you know making a decision
about what we ought to do is the one who
has a solid understanding of moral
values now that may sound a little
strange to you at first
and that's actually a sign of how bad
our culture is
we tend to say what people have values
and we look at in a very subjective way
Plato thought of this in terms of
something more objective that there
actually were right and wrong good and
bad you could arrange things in kind of
a hierarchy and some people were well
oriented towards that other people were
totally off in in their own sort of lala
land and out of touch with what those
values were they may have had their own
values for example if somebody thinks
that making a ton of money is the best
thing in life Plato would say sure that
person has that belief they're wrong
they actually are out of touch with what
is in fact really good for them and he
talks in terms of three modalities here
the ancient Greeks had a number of
different valued words that were very
important just versus unjust you know
what is right in the situation what is
called for by say the laws are called
for by propriety what what is the right
thing to do or what would be the wrong
thing to do where am i violating
somebody's rightful claims on me were
they I actually owe them something
that's one important modality of moral
values another one that he talks about
this was very important for the ancient
Greeks it's also very important for us
although we use different language for
it is the honorable and the dishonorable
or sometimes you'll see it translated as
the noble and the base or the beautiful
and the ugly the Cologne and I scone the
Greeks that'll you know these two terms
that were used for all these different
types of value and you know some of this
we might say well that's purely
aesthetic what's beautiful or what's
ugly but we can talk in terms of moral
beauty if you say that person is a
beautiful person and you don't just mean
looking at their form that you know they
turn you on or something like that
but you mean I really like the person
that they are I think there's something
something awesome about them something
breathtaking something startling
something I really admire
so we would call in this case the
Honorable on the other hand if you say
that person disgusts me by the kind of
person that they are now you're talking
about the dishonorable the ice phone and
then there's the the good versus the bad
this is showing us that it doesn't all
fit into these two neat categories of
the just and unjust and the noble and
the base or the the fine and the the
ignoble or however you want to put it
there's also goodness and badness in
other modalities and Socrates is not
spending time here trying to to explain
this to us he's just sort of citing this
and he does this in other dialogues as
well particularly the gorgeous where he
uses exactly those same categories
Aristotle believes those categories as
well so in any case the wise person
actually has understanding or knowledge
of what is in general you know good or
bad and then they can apply it to
particular cases
now why bring up all this Socrates says
in this case who do we want to listen to
do we want to listen to the many who are
wrong and whose views are actually bad
because they're harmful they damage not
only one's own interests or something
like that but they damage what's most
valuable in a person that is their soul
or personality what it is that makes
them them their integrity you might
think of it if you rely on the many in
moral matters to make sense of things
you're really taking a big risk of
getting a lettuce tray on the other hand
if you go to somebody who actually is
knowledgeable about moral matters they
may not only you know help you out in
that situation and say well here's what
you need to do so that you don't damage
you know what's most valuable about you
you may actually get in them somebody
who can help you grow and do something
that's even better they're they're
helpful in that respect so Socrates is
saying this is the person that we want
to go to notice that you doesn't say I
am that person by the way
credo he doesn't say who would actually
be that person he's doing something a
bit more negative he's saying forget
these dummies over here we don't need to
listen to them what we want is somebody
like this and so one of the questions
that I'm going to leave you with is well
who would that person be for Plato or
Socrates and are the laws that we're
going to talk about in another concert
video are the laws who are making an
argument are they in some way
substituting for this person